over a million cases and counting
a daily spike with no signs of it
peaking let alone a plateau
with almost 35 000 new cases in the last
24 hours
india is the third worst affected
country in the world
37 year old deepak overcame a fever last
week
but his family insisted he do a test
it's turned out positive
yes of course i'm scared i have a family
and children
i never thought it would be positive
out of the 10 people tested at the time
we were at the camp
three are positive a warning that the
contagion
is accelerating
at the covet dedicated ambulance control
room
sanjay and his colleague jayvendra
answer over
150 calls a day
they coordinate and track 38 ambulances
in a district that caters to four and a
half
million inhabitants of gaza bad a town
adjoining the country's capital
in the beginning i was afraid but not
anymore i believe i am doing good work
and so i will not get the disease
for months i have had no symptoms
as we speak a call has come in to
transfer a five-year-old girl to a
hospital
as she's tested positive
stigma attached to this disease has
forced the mother and daughter to wait
away
from the neighborhood they will now
spend the next two weeks
in quarantine
close to a hundred doctors have died so
far
and dr abhishek bayana was the youngest
at just
26. a shattered family told me
that he complained of kovitz symptoms
but had no prior medical conditions
he was rushed to a hospital but died
within a week
this is like a nightmare that we are in
i'm still not able to admit that is
normal
parents will be scared to let their
children become doctors
and send them on the front line from now
on
their lives are far more precious to us
the bhayana family still grieves the
loss of the youngest member
and india has lost another doctor to
combat the growing pandemic
neville lazarus sky news delhi